bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur
tvfils 78 pour le journal de la
rédaction en CE2 avril voici les
principaux titres qui seront développés
au cours de la prochaine demi-heure et
lui au conseil municipal de Trappes ce
week-end le député de la 11e
circonscription des Yvelines Benoît
Hamon passe du ministère de l'économie
sociale et solidaire à celui de
l'éducation le président UMP du conseil
général Alain Schmitt explique les
raisons de son départ et sur le retour
annoncé également de son prédécesseur
Pierre Bédié Alexandra Rosetti ancien
adjointe d'Alexis
UMPS s'impose à la tête de la mairie de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux une victoire
serrée elle invitée de cette édition le
nouveau gouvernement a donc été annoncé
ce matin livelinois Benoît Hamon et
figure toujours et lui dimanche dernier
conseiller municipal de la majorité de
Guy malandins à Trappes et lui aussi
pour siéger à la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin il a
été nommé ministre de l'Éducation
nationale de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la Recherche quel poids dans les
Yvelines qu'elles enjeux dans les
Yvelines se reportage
et le député de la onzième
circonscription des Yvelines en juin
2012 Benoît Hamon a encore jamais siéger
au Palais Bourbon membre du gouvernement
de François Hollande à l'économie
sociale et solidaire il doit comme le
prévoit la loi laisser la place à son
suppléant Jean-Philippe Mallet et on se
2 avril ce dernier voit son séjour se
prolonger puisque c'est au poste de
ministre de l'éducation de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche que vient d'être nommé celui
que l'on présente comme l'homme fort de
l'aile gauche de la gauche Benoît Hamon
également élu dimanche conseiller
municipal à trappe sur la liste de Guy
Malandain est conseillé communautaire à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines mais il
siègerait alors dans l'opposition au
ministère de l'Éducation nationale qui
regroupe dorénavant celui de
l'enseignement supérieur Benoît Hamon
est très attendu sur la question des
rythmes scolaires notamment lancé par
son prédécesseur Vincent Peillon une
réforme que de nombreux mères refusent
d'appliquer en septembre et notamment
l'un de ses principaux rivaux
Jean-Michel fourgousse merdé-lancourt à
Bois-d'Arcy celui qui vient de ravir la
ville au PS Philippe Benassaya annonce
aussi mettre en suspens la réforme et
puis sur le plan local toujours que dire
de l'Université de Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines que la dorénavant ancienne
ministre Geneviève fioration accusé de
mauvaises gestion poussant l'état
intervenir pour combler un déficit
mettant à mal sa survie là aussi les
prochaines déclarations de Benoît Hamon
sont pour le moins attendus dans le
département par les principaux concernés
qu'ils soient enseignants syndicalistes
présidents d'université ou tout
simplement étudiant
et les réactions n'ont pas manqué dans
le département après ce remaniement on
notera tout d'abord le tweet de Valérie
Pécresse la responsable UMP dans le
département en fin de matinée les
Français n'attendent pas un casting mais
une ligne politique une direction claire
un espoir ou encore cette autre tweet
celui d'Isabelle tissinjean conseillère
régional d'Île-de-France socialiste en
charge de l'enseignement supérieur
justement elle est aussi conseillère
municipal d'opposition à Versailles et
l'adresse avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme
c'est félicitations à Benoît Hamon
écoutez à présent l'échange qui s'est
déroulé hier sur ce plateau entre eux
Sandrine grand gambe la responsable
départementale du Parti socialiste et
Jean-Michel fourgousse mer UMPS
Élancourt battu au législatives par
Benoît Hamon et qui va sans aucun doute
poursuivre son bras de fer contre le
nouveau ministre de l'éducation pour
demander l'annulation de la réforme des
rythmes scolaires lui qui refuse de
l'appliquer dans sa commune
quelle est la compétence de Monsieur
Hamon moi je la cherche je l'ai toujours
pas trouvé
une compétence
pour pour le territoire au moins dans sa
famille politique on considère que c'est
un atout vous êtes sur ces reconnais
parce que Monsieur monsieur
libérale donc il faut mettre l'extrême
gauche je n'ai pas en tête que Benoît
soit le représentant de l'extrême gauche
française
mais sur le fond sur la politique menée
qu'attendez-vous de se remaniement
ministériel c'est notre question du jour
rien ne changera je pense quand même que
c'est quelque part une bonne chose si on
peut dire une bonne chose c'est là voilà
pour ce micro-trottoir à retrouver
peut-être d'ici la fin de cette édition
ou bien évidemment dans la prochaine
édition du Journal de la rédaction on
passe à présent à cette autre actualité
politique actualité politique chargée on
se débute semaine en poste depuis 2009
Alain Schmitt a donc annoncé son départ
hier et de la présidence du Conseil
Général des Yvelines ce matin il s'est
longuement expliqué devant la presse sur
les raisons de ce départ Catherine
zulato et Jonathan Willmann
à la Schmitz bonjour bonjour vous avez
annoncé mardi 1er avril que vous alliez
quitté au 10 avril à la présidence du
Conseil Général alors d'abord pourquoi
ce choix qui est un peu étonnant parce
qu'il y a quelques mois quand le
conseiller général du canton de Montigny
François Denis vous avez posé la
question vous aviez dit non non je
resterai jusqu'au bout de mon mandat il
vous restez un an à faire oui parce que
je ne voulais en aucun cas que cette
décision qui était prise depuis
longtemps et je vous expliquais dans
quel contexte puisse interférer avec les
élections municipales considéré que ça
n'était pas le sujet c'est poser le
problème de la réforme territoriale de
l'émergence de la métropole
du devenir de nos départements de
grandes couronnes et je me suis dit
qu'il n'était pas normal que je n'évoque
pas et que je n'assume pas la
responsabilité de ma succession en
laissant en quelque sorte la place libre
le lendemain des élections 2015 suite
était inconcevable qui est pas de patron
à la barre du navire Yvelines si vous
voulez le 11 avril précisément en séance
du conseil général sera
élu le nouveau président du conseil
général on parle de père bélier confirmé
je le souhaite personnellement parce que
de tous mes collègues je suis sûr que
c'est lui qui fera certainement la plus
grande unanimité au sein de sa famille
politique il est fort de son expérience
qui est reconnu de sa compétence de son
engagement au service des Yvelines il
l'a montré en d'autres temps il le
montrera dans l'avenir sans aucun doute
et comme je vous l'ai dit c'est une
période particulièrement troublée
institutionnellement parlant que nous
allons traverser avec de grosses
difficultés en termes de ressources
financières pour le pour le département
et il fallait quelqu'un qui puisse faire
entendre la voix des Yvelines alors
pierre-y qui avait été président du
conseil général de 2005 à 2009 qui avait
dû quitter le conseil général en raison
des affaires on va dire ça comme ça du
coup ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
la chemise vous avez assuré l'intérim
pour permettre à Pierre-Bénite une fois
qu'il avait purger sa peine entre
guillemets
politique souvent indéniablement c'est
un temps extrêmement politique qui
s'ouvre maintenant et donc il fallait
qu'il y ait quelqu'un de très politique
à la tête du département n'est pas
politique
de 3 juillet 2009 puisque c'était à ce
moment-là
jusque au 11 avril 2014 quel est votre
plus belle fierté puis peut-être un peu
votre déception en tout cas le dossier
dans lequel vous n'êtes pas allé
jusqu'au bout vous ne pourrez pas
le développement de l'attractivité des
Yvelines je crois voilà avoir renforcé
fort d'une réelle puissance financière
si vous voulez d'un poids économique
conséquent d'avoir renforcé
l'attractivité du département des
Yvelines à travers par exemple le plan
Yvelines l'amélioration programmée des
transports en commun qui est essentiels
le développement des logements j'ai
quand même multiplié par deux la
production de logements de 3000 à
ce combat au service des de nos plus
petites communes merci à ma fille merci
avant de recevoir dans un instant
plateau Alexandra Rosetti nouvelle maire
de Voisins le bretonneux retour sur
cette déclaration hier sur notre plateau
de Jean-Michel fourgousse le maire
d'Élancourt a annoncé et que la
présidence de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin devrait échouer à Michel
Laugier le maire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il sera en tout
cas le candidat de la droite lors du
vote interne entre les élus d'ici deux
semaines la date de ce premier conseil
n'a pas encore été arrêté
je crois que bon avec Michel logier bon
on a on est les deux plus gros entre
guillemets qui avons apporté un peu
cette victoire bon donc bien entendu on
s'est vu et on a décidé d'une d'une
présidente le plus horizontale possible
moi je lui demande je non je lui ai
demandé de prendre la présidence
avec un pôle économique très important
puisque c'est un peu mon un peu ma
sensibilité mes compétences plutôt voilà
parce que d'abord il faut j'ai aussi des
j'ai aussi un axe un peu national vous
le savez bon voilà et j'ai bien entendu
j'ai ma commune d'Élancourt donc il faut
être conscient il faut équilibrer ça je
pense que c'est le meilleur équilibre
donc voilà nous on recentrera
certainement sur la création de gestes
sur la création d'emploi sur Créer créer
de main bien sûr des des nouvelles
logiques du genre Silicon Valley on
aimerait que la casse qui soit le
premier étage d'une future Silicon
Valley ou vraiment vous aurez une élite
entrepreneuriale avec des postes
d'ingénieurs vous voyez de techn
Massy ou sur je sais qu'il y a beaucoup
de de discussions sur le périmètre nous
par exemple on propose déjà un
élargissement sur sur Coignières sur
Maurepas sur plaisir sur les clés
à noter vous l'avez entendu que les
nouveaux contours de l'agglomération se
dessine des villes pourraient aussi
rejoindre 50 ans en Yvelines afin
d'atteindre le seuil de 200000 habitants
comme le prévoit à la loi qui rentrera
en vigueur en 2016 plaisir Maurepas
Villepreux les clés communes elle aussi
à droite sont les plus souvent
mentionnés je reçois donc à présent
Alexandra Rosetti bonsoir bienvenue sur
ce plateau nouvelle maire de Voisins le
bretonneux élu ce dimanche d'une courte
tête on va revoir les résultats qui vont
s'afficher bien évidemment ancien
adjointe d'Alexis vous avez réussi à
l'emporter face à lui après avoir
démissionné et condamné ses choix
également quand on revoit ce score serré
ce que vous vous attendiez à ça d'autant
plus que vous partiez de très très loin
et vous n'aviez aucun soutien politique
même si vous êtes à l'ude vous n'avez
pas soutenu pendant cette campagne oui
clairement effectivement
on y a cru on y a cru jusqu'au bout en
fait je sais pas on était animée d'un
d'une telle envie que on s'est battu et
on s'est battu effectivement malgré
malgré les parties voilà on a voulu
prouver aux vicinois que ce qui comptait
c'était le projet pour la ville et pas
uniquement une bagarre sur le terrain
politique je pense que j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire ici en débat j'ai
vraiment regretté que tout se passe sur
le terrain des parties des parties je
crois que il faut qu'on travaille tous
ensemble et pour l'avenir de la ville
quoi et c'est ça qui compte alors oui
effectivement ce que vous gardez une
rancœur par rapport à l'UDI est-ce que
vous êtes encore aujourd'hui à l'UDI
est-ce que les choses vont mieux je ne
suis pas rancunière de nature déjà donc
ça c'est quand même un point très
positif non ça m'amuse un petit peu
parce que je sais que bon j'ai pas eu
l'investiture udi parce qu'il y a eu des
accords
umpudie pour arranger le député
un Nourrichard dans son propre à la
propre ville où il se présentait et puis
il n'a pas été élu donc je me dis que
quelque part il y a un petit peu il y a
une justice quand même et que je suis
contente que les vicinois n'est pas
regardé que le
partielle c'est un peu normal quand même
je veux dire je crois que je suis pas la
seule élue qu'il a un peu laissé en plan
sur les investitures donc je trouve que
bon c'est dommage pour lui je pense que
pour l'udaïs aurait été bien qu'il soit
élu évidemment mais c'est vrai que d'un
point de vue personnel je regrette qu'il
est pas voulu faire confiance à une
femme que il est misé sur le maire
sortant parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
fait d'habitude je regrette que l'UDI
n'est pas eu ce courage là justement
vous le faites remarquer vous êtes une
femme et vous avez réussi à gagner cette
cette commune c'est une première aussi
dans l'agglomération Yvelines une femme
qui va siéger dans l'agglomération
peut-être une remarque par rapport à ça
une fierté en tout cas est-ce que vous y
pensez forcément vous venez de l'évoquer
d'ailleurs ah bah c'est toujours un
petit peu émouvant de se dire qu'on est
la première de quelque chose après je
pense pas que sur le fond ça change
grand chose
voilà parce que bon et après je pense
vraiment que une femme peut apporter
autre chose un autre regard c'était mon
slogan et je pense qu'il nous a vraiment
collé à la peau tout au long de la
campagne et je pense que un regard
féminin fera sans doute beaucoup de bien
aussi voilà ce milieu qui sonne tout
reste très masculin on se rend compte
que je crois qu'il y avait 83% des têtes
de liste en France qui étaient
masculines donc on sent bien que la
parité c'est pas ça de moi c'était dans
un article la parité s'arrête au bord du
pouvoir quelque part donc je trouve que
c'est une belle victoire pour ça aussi
la compagnie est terminée aujourd'hui
est-ce que les choses sont apaisées à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux on vous a entendu
ici sur ce plateau avec les autres
postulants en poste de mer et notamment
Alexis Viet Lemaire sortant les échange
était tendu aujourd'hui vous échangez
avec Alexis Viette qui est aujourd'hui
la principale force d'opposition sur la
commune je n'ai aucune nouvelle
j'estime que c'est pas à moi de voilà je
pense il aurait été bon qu'il y ait une
passation mais pas le rencontrer avant
le premier conseil municipal pour la
passation qui est prévue à la fin de
l'aspect de lui vous avez sollicité cet
entretien en tout cas vous attendez
qu'il se tend vers vous voilà ça me
semble logique mais bon s'il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas il y aura pas ça ne ça
changera rien au fond du sujet on se
mettra au travail dès lundi et comment
vous imaginez justement la tenue de ces
différents conseils municipaux face à
Alexis Biet vous étiez à ses côtés dans
la majorité en tant qu'adjointe ensuite
vous êtes partis on peut finalement
imaginer que vos prises de décision ne
sont peut-être pas si éloignées de ce
qu'il aurait pu lui proposer donc il va
vous soutenir je ne sais pas nous
verrons ça c'est à lui de le dire je ne
sais pas si nos prises de positions je
pense qu'il y aura des choses sur
lesquelles on ne sera forcément pas
d'accord je l'ai assez répété parce que
vous étiez dans la même majorité c'est
encore une fois je crois que on peut pas
tout ramener à la politique c'est pas
parce que on a une tendance où j'ai une
sensibilité plus à droite que on va se
retrouver surtout je pense que sinon je
vais rester avec lui
ensemble pendant quasiment toute une
mandature oui moi je suis tout à fait de
toute façon des projets de ce qui a été
on va remettre un certain nombre de
choses à plat de toute façon je crois
que c'est l'attente de la population
sinon ils auraient pas voté pour moi au
bout du compte donc si il y a du travail
après il y a comme je l'ai dit moi j'ai
jamais dit que le bilan était désastreux
comme disait Monsieur H mais je pense
franchement qu'il y a quand même un
certain nombre de choses sur lesquelles
il faut qu'on vienne et en particulier
pour faire des économies donc voilà nous
on va on va plutôt travailler sur cet
axe là
aussi mais vraiment en position
minoritaire au conseil municipal nous
disait que finalement ça ne changerait
pas forcément grand chose en tout cas
c'était ça craintes que vous soyez élu
et que les choses ne changent pas vous
lui répondez quoi et quels sont alors
les choses qui vont changer peut-être
le jeu de la campagne électorale bien
sûr un changement pour rien bon ben on
jugera sur les actes et puis moi j'ai
l'intention de toute façon premier
changement c'est que j'ai l'intention de
travailler avec tout le monde et ça je
l'ai dit dans un de mes derniers tracts
et je me suis engagé donc je vais ouvrir
je vais ouvrir certains sujets de façon
un petit peu plus vaste je parle un peu
je pense en particulier au finance à
l'urbanisme je pense que ces sujets ne
peuvent pas se régler dans un bureau
entre quatre personnes je pense vraiment
qu'il faut partager parce que je
j'ai compris moi dans cette campagne que
les vicinois comprenait parfaitement
qu'il y avait des soucis des problèmes
financiers parce que tout le monde
rencontre aussi et que il voulait qu'il
voulait comprendre il voulait qu'on leur
explique il voulait éventuellement être
associé sur les choix et ça c'est
quelque chose qui pour moi a été une
tendance très très forte je pense que le
changement principal ça va être la façon
d'écouter les habitants sur vos
priorités sur le dossier prioritaire
alors le dossier prioritaire c'est les
rythmes scolaires voilà là qu'il faut
décider très très vite la façon de faire
et puis l'urbanisme qui frappe déjà à la
porte avec déjà des dépôts de permis de
construire donc
très très vite en fait je pense que je
vais aller à la rencontre de certains
habitants sur les rythmes scolaires
justement vous allez mettre en place
cette réforme où vous allez la boycoter
comme c'est le cas sur des communes
comme la commune d'Élancourt par exemple
ou encore des communes voisines comme
celle de Bois-d'Arcy Philippe qui
suspend un petit peu la mise en place de
la réforme non non parce que c'est de
toute façon c'est un je veux dire c'est
une loi
qui vient d'être donc nommé aujourd'hui
au ministère de l'éducation qui est du
département des Yvelines députée de la
11e circonscription reviennent peut-être
sur cette réforme c'est ce que vous
souhaitez ou pas en tout cas ce sera son
choix moi sur ce type de réforme puisque
mon métier est à moi justement d'être
enseignante et de subir les réformes
d'éducation nationale ministre après
ministre faut dire ce qui est moi ce qui
me gêne beaucoup dans ce type de réforme
c'est le fait que on nous l'a on nous
l'impose et on ne nous donne pas de
solution nous donne pas de clés c'est
débrouillez-vous chacun fait comme il
peut donc je crois qu'il va falloir que
enfin moi mon intention c'est de
beaucoup partager avec les autres villes
donc l'intention c'est de la mettre en
oeuvre là de la rentrée puisque de toute
façon les services on travaillait dessus
donc je verrai ça la semaine prochaine
mais effectivement il y a tout un
travail de mis en place et puis tout de
suite très vite après me tourner vers
les autres villes pour voir ce qu'ils
ont fait
éventuellement remettre des choses en
question après travailler sur une
évaluation avec les personnes concernées
parce que c'est une réforme à mon avis
très importante et qui va peser lourd
sur le budget de la commune donc elle
sera mise en place
je respecte la loi c'est je commence à
pas respecter de la loi tu peux gênant
pour un pour un maire tranquille voisin
Bretonneux pour s'intéresser à
l'agglomération de 50 ans vous allez
siéger dans la majorité justement vous
êtes de sensibilité
udi sur cette agglomération de
Saint-Quentin vous l'avez déjà dit vous
n'êtes pas intéressé par la présidence
mais est-ce que vous avez échangé avec
Jean-Michel fourgon avec Michel Laugier
Jean-Michel fourgouse qui sort ce
plateau hier annoncé que ce serait
Michel Laugier qui serait le candidat
parce que avec lui le représentait les
deux plus grosses communes plus gros
poids dans l'agglomération vous avez
l'impression d'ailleurs un peu
l'impression que la la victoire revient
à Montigny et parcours bon faut quand
même rappeler que si j'avais pas été là
c'était il y aurait eu un siège de toute
façon à la gauche de la part de chez
voisin donc la victoire à mon avis à
droite et une seule liste effectivement
pour la gauche la voisine du coup
vraiment pour beaucoup dans cette
victoire mais bon c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas très important c'est pas le
sujet
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
quelle place pour voisin Bretonneux tout
simplement je pense qu'on aura notre
place évidemment je évidemment qu'on
aura des vice-présidents donc on
travaillera sur les sujets sur des
sujets j'espère important bien entendu
j'ai rencontré Monsieur logis j'ai vu
monsieur fourgon c'est évidemment et
j'ai bien évidemment dit que nous
voulions nous voulions être associés et
travailler comme euh aucun souci sur la
question qui vous intéresserait qu'elle
vice-président éventuellement je ne je
ne vais pas aller aussi loin que ça
parce que il pourrait y avoir plusieurs
entre Jean-Michel Fourou c'est Michel
moi je pense que peut-être mais mes
domaines de compétences on va dire moi
j'ai été à la commission culture avant
donc c'est quelque chose que je connais
bien mais je suis ouverte à couverte à
beaucoup de choses parce que et très lu
c'est pas être forcément dans une
compétence qu'on maîtrise ça peut être
aussi en découvrir d'autres et on
travaille on travaille avec les autres
élus dans les commissions donc je pense
qu'on peut être à même travailler sur
beaucoup de sujets en fait voilà merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau nouvelle mère
de voisins le Bretonneau après cette
victoire donc face à Alexis Viet le
maire sortant
après la politique nous reprenons le
cours de ce journal pour revenir sur le
salon esprit jardin de Versailles ou un
stand tenu par l'association Enfance de
l'art permettait de découvrir les
animaux de la basse-cour et les
avantages qu'une poule peut permettre à
votre domicile et oui Olivier Maniscalco
Anthony Reich se sont montrés très
intéressé
adopter une poule pour votre jardin
proposez les 29 et 30 mars par
l'association Enfance de l'art sur le
salon esprit jardin de Versailles l'idée
peut d'abord paraître cocasse mais à
l'instar du mouton doué son qui va
tondre écologiquement votre pelouse la
poule peut vite devenir votre allié pour
s'occuper du potager
tous les animaux nuisibles pour le
potager bon du coup c'est vraiment une
poule une poule ou les oies c'est pareil
ou le canard c'est le compagnon et
l'aide du jardinier alors ça dépend des
saisons quand c'est le moment des
plantations faut être très vigilant et
dans ce cas-là essayez de contener la
poule dans un petit espace la poule va
également aider au compost en favorisant
le recyclage des déchets ménagers et
malgré ses nombreux avantages elle le
demande que peu d'attention on se rend
compte que finalement c'est quelque
chose de très très simple il y a juste à
changer un petit peu la paille en
contrepartie on a des œufs on a les une
relation avec l'animal qui est assez
assez docile donc on peut caresser la la
prendre la montrer aux enfants il y a
beaucoup plus d'avantages que de
d'inconvénients avoir une poule au
jardin
côté la ferme du piqueur peut vous
permettre d'adopter une poule durant vos
vacances l'établissement peut même
servir de pension pour votre animal
l'association recommande de toutefois
d'éviter de prendre un coq pour la
tranquillité de vos voisins
les joueuses du club de tennis de table
d'Élancourt sont championne de France de
Pro B hier soir à domicile elles ont
dominé les pongistes et de Mayenne
pourtant en tête du championnat et va au
dorova apporter envie expérience de
matchs de victoire pour la Slovaque pour
le compte des yvelinoises square final
de l'équipe d'Élancourt 4 à 1 et long
court sacré à trois journées de la fin
du championnat nous en parlerons bien
sûr dans la prochaine édition du 7 8
sport ce lundi sport toujours mais
également handicap le 30 mars dernier
une marche était organisée à Versailles
au profit des handicapés sportives de
haut niveau un rendez-vous organisé par
les inerwheels une ONG qui œuvre pour
l'amitié le service et l'entente
internationale Yolaine Torres
monsieur félicitations
pour sa quatrième édition la marche a
réuni une centaine de personnes un
événement organisé par la première ONG
féminine mondiale inerwheel objectif
Féder les femmes handicapées sportives
de haut niveau à progresser dans leur
discipline c'est très important parce
que c'est handicapés sportif de haut
niveau n'ont pas tellement de de revenus
entre guillemets donc par cette marche
qui est nationale donc toutes les tous
les clubs innorwheels de France Maroc
Tunisie et Andorre qu'elles sont
rattachées également font cette marche
aujourd'hui dans tout dans tous les
départements c'est une marche nationale
parmi les participants des femmes bien
sûr mais aussi des hommes investis pour
cette cause féminine ils ont parcouru
plus de 6 km autour du grand canal de
Versailles c'est un moment de rencontre
c'est un moment d'espace en plus avec la
météo d'aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement
agréable c'est pas l'eau du tout parce
que d'habitude nous le faisons en
footing donc c'était très agréable on
échange un moment très privilégié fondé
il y a 90 ans le club Inner will encore
peu connu se définit comme la roue
intérieure du Rotary Club ses origines
remontent à la fin de la Première Guerre
mondiale les épouses de Rotariens de
Grande-Bretagne et d'Irlande
continuaient à se réunir en y invitant
les veuves et les filles célibataires
des Rotariens disparus
prochaine édition du 7 8 Lexus sur TVfil
78 demain jeudi 18h invité Michel logier
maire de Montigny le Bretonneux qui
devrait être le prochain président de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez
retrouver toutes nos précédentes
éditions en replay ainsi que l'ensemble
des reportages de tvfils 78 et
l'actualité locale ce commente aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux excellente soirée